翻訳: Hiroko Kawano
校正: Claire Ghyselen
（謡い）「老いせぬや
老いせぬや
薬の名をも
菊の水
盃も
浮かみ出でて
友に逢うぞ嬉しき
又 友に逢うぞ嬉しき」
こんにちは
宇髙竜成（うだかたつしげ）です
よろしくお願いします
（拍手）
僕は能楽師という仕事をしています
初舞台は３歳の頃でした
でもあまり舞台のことが
よく分かっていなかったので
２階席にいる母親を見つけて笑ったり
挙句の果てには
舞台の上で寝てしまいました
（笑）こんな初舞台です
小学校のころですね
よく友達に
「お能ってなんなん？」とか
「そんなん 面白いの？」って
言われたんですけれども
その時の僕はうまく答えることが
できませんでした
それで時間が過ぎて
今の僕がいるわけなんですけれども
今なら友達に「お能って面白いよ」
と言うことができるようになりました
皆さんはお能を見たことはありますか？
はい
まだ見たことがない人の中には
こういうイメージを持っている人たちが
多いと思います
「難しい」「敷居が高い」
「自分なんかが見に行ったら
退屈して寝てしまうかもしれない」
その気持ちはよく分かります
（笑）
僕もそのこんな状態から
今 面白いと言えるように
なるまでになったんですね
じゃあ どうしたら面白いようになるか？
それはですね 自分とのつながりを
見つけるということです
お能なんて関係ないと
思っていたとしてもですね
そこからひとつ
つながりを見つけることで
どんどんお能が面白く
なっていくんですね
能は日本の仮面劇です
これが能面です
ヒノキでできています
種類は200種類ぐらいあります
この女性は
平安時代のお化粧をしています
まゆを剃って上に描いて
お歯黒を施しています
現代のお化粧とかなり違うと思います
この女性 恋をしています
これは現代の女性でも
同じ心だと思います
恋人になかなか会えないときというのは
このように下の方を向けて行って
寂しそうな顔をします
そこに恋人が訪ねてくると
このように
嬉しそうに笑いかけます
おわかりになったか
ちょっと 自信がないんですが
能面は表情を変えることのできる
仮面なんです
この仮面を使って
少しパフォーマンスをしたいと思います
『井筒』という曲の中で 登場する女性は
在原業平の初恋の相手です
やがて二人は結ばれて
夫婦になるんですけれども
亡くなって
この世を去ったあとも
その恋人のことを想い続けます
業平の形見の衣を身にまとって
昔を思い出します
ではちょっとこの仮面を使って
謡いを謡ってみたいと思います
（謡い）「徒なりと 名にこそ立てれ
桜花
年に稀なる
人も待ちけり
かやうに（かように）詠みしも
我なれば
人待つ女と言は（わ）れしなり
我 筒井筒（つついづつ）の
昔より
真弓 槻弓（まゆみつきゆみ）
年を経て
今は亡き世に業平（なりひら）の
形見の直衣（のうし）
身にふれて
懐かしや
昔男に
移舞（うつりまい）」
（拍手）
能楽師は能面を扱うときは
袴を穿けと言われます
それはこの能面 そして登場人物
これを代々伝えてきた役者に
礼儀を尽くすということです
代々の役者が礼儀を尽くしてきましたので
例えば500年前の能面を
今でも 舞台の上で使うことができます
能面に礼儀を尽くして扱うという
その心が
今の能役者と昔の能役者と
つながっているんですね
心がつながっています
この能面の視界が
どれぐらい狭いかというのを
皆さんに
体験していただきたいと思います
あの ちょっとカードを
ご用意していただいて
目に当ててみてください
はい ちょっと マイクが あれですけども
このようにかなり 見えません
あの 上と下が逆の方が
いらっしゃいます（笑）
これで歩くと
ふらふらしてしまいますので
腰を落として
摺り足をすることになります
そして摺り足をして歩くということで
ダンスの方法としては
上下運動の「踊り」ではなくて
旋回運動の「舞い」になります
「舞う」ということばは
「回る」が語源だそうです
次に 能の表現方法について
お話をしたいと思います
今からやる動きを
みなさん想像してみてください
「刀を抜く」
「筆を使う」
こうやると
お酒を飲むことができます
このように能の表現というのは
みなさんの想像力をお借りして
表現して行くやり方なんですね
「幽玄」と言われるような
表現方法というのは
敢えてそのものを隠してしまって
見えない部分を想像してもらう
というような表現方法です
例えば 春になると山に桜が咲きます
きれいだなあと思いながら
ついつい見とれてしまう
というような感じになるわけですね
この想像力を掻き立たせる
というのが
僕たち役者の仕事です
例えば 「近くの桜」だとか
「遠くの桜」だとか
このようにスピードで距離感を出したり
することもできるわけですね
想像力を使うというのは
少し大変なことなんですけれども
幽玄と想像力が合わさったときには
とっても自由になります
それでは 今から 短い舞を
お見せしたいと思います
『熊野（ゆや）』という曲の一節で
清水寺から 春の京都を眺める
というシーンです
今やった 桜を見るという動きと
謡いとでやってみたいと思います
（謡）「立ち出でて
峰の雲
花やあらん
初桜（はつざくら）の」
こんな感じになります
もう一つ お見せしたいと思いますが
『殺生石（せっしょうせき）』
という曲の一節で
僕は狩人の役をします
これは弓に見立てます
九尾の狐を追って行くんですけれども
狐はそのあたりにいるので
皆さんで想像してみてください
そして追っかけて行って
矢を撃つんですけれども
最終に僕は狩人から狐に
この弓は矢に変わって
矢を射られるというところを
お見せします
（謡）「身を何と那須野の原に
現れ出でしを狩人の
追っつつまくっつさくりにつけて
矢の下に射っ伏せらるれば
即時に命を徒（いたづら）に」
というような動きです
（拍手）
このように お能の動きは
色々な動きを織り交ぜて
表現をしていきます
だんだん興味が湧いて
きましたでしょうか？
さらに 今みたいに
歌詞を予め知っておくと
想像力というのは
どんどん膨らんで行きます
例えば 海外のロックバンドの
ライブに行く前に
日本語訳をこう 読みながら
聴き込むのと同じだと思います
さらに今はインターネット
というものがありますので
調べることは簡単にできます
もしかしたら現代がお能を一番楽しむ
ことができる時代なのかもしれません
想像力というのは人の心を豊かにします
そしてこの豊かな心は昔の
亡くなってしまった人の心と通じ合ったり
失われてしまった
綺麗な景色をイメージしたり
場所や時間を超えて
つながることができます
さらに未来の人たちも僕たちと
想像力でつながることができます
伝統芸能は
昔に始まった芸能なんですけれども
今を生きている芸能です
さらにその伝統には
未来があります
今日ここで
興味を持っていただいた方々の
繋がりと想像力を使って
これからの未来を
創っていきたいと思っております
どうぞよろしくお願いします
（拍手）
ありがとうございました